the A to Z of isms Orientalism the late
academic Edward Sayid developed the term
Orientalism to describe how Europeans
portrayed the Orient as inferior
uncivilized and all-around weird but
importantly Sayid argued this was also
simultaneously about defining Europe as
the Orient's opposite superior civilized
and all-around wonderful the actual term
the Orient refers to the rising of the
Sun in the east and comes from the Latin
word Orient
so we can think of Orientalism as
Eastern ism or stereotyping of the east
Orientalism then is the form of
knowledge in quotation marks that
authorizes and justifies the assertion
of Western power over the East but what
does this actually mean
Orientalism acts like a pair of glasses
that distort your vision and exaggerate
cultural and religious differences with
these glasses just about everything and
everyone seems highly exotic and strange
or worse fanatical and dangerous women
in the Middle East for example appear
only as exotic a belly dancer or
oppressed a quote-unquote veiled woman
with no nuances in-between and in the
early 20th century you might have seen
men portrayed as exotically romantic or
more recently as crazy and fanatical a
terrorist and miss all the ordinary
human beings along the way many Arabs
Muslims and Asians embraces
controversial term to describe the
unique kind of races and they experience
Orientalism encapsulate for many how
their culture religion and ethnicity are
so often reduced to a stereotype causing
their humanity to be overlooked and
culture misunderstood isn't this just a
form of stereotyping then well yes and
no Orientalism is about a much broader
set of power relations when the US
government views the Middle East through
Orientals glasses
it creates policies with far-reaching
consequences from outright war waged on
other countries to imposing a travel ban
on whole groups of people perhaps the
trickiest thing about Orientalism is
that it's not fueled by ignorance or a
simple lack of knowledge just the
opposite it has historically been
produced as no
by those in positions of power whether
government officials religious figures
or the media for example when President
Trump stated I think Islam hates us we
can't allow people coming into this
country you have this hatred for the
United States he effectively
characterized for 1.6 billion Muslims
worldwide as anti-american even today
Orientalism continues because it is so
engrained in how we see other peoples
and cultures that it goes unnoticed even
the term the Middle East is considered
to be Orientalist because it
standardizes a Western viewpoint by
referring to West Asia and North Africa
as the middle of the East much of what
counts as knowledge about the Middle
East and parts of Asia is still produced
through those distorting and reductive
glasses and just like in the 18th and
19th centuries Orientalism remains
powerful because it shapes not just how
people in the West view the East but
also how they view themselves
you